(swishing)
(playful music)
(machines beeping)
- Hi sir, can I help you?
- Hi, I've been having some
really bad stomach pains,
and I was wondering if there's a doctor
that can see me right now?
- Oh my god.
I'm' so sorry to hear that, of course.
Just make a left, and
he'll see you right away.
(dopey music)
(clearing throat)
- Hi, I've been having
really bad stomach pains.
I was wondering if there's a doctor
that could see me right now.
(forms slamming)
- Fill these forms out.
We'll get to you when we can.
(dopey music)
(intense music)
(sexy music)
(woman moaning)
- Don't worry, I've got you.
(intense music)
(corny music)
- Hello.
(intense music)
- Alright everyone, I've got a
partial colectomy situation here,
so let's get him prepped,
and start the incision.
But, this shirt looks
kinda nice, and expensive.
Let's get this off him
nicely and laundered,
for when he gets outta here.
(slow orchestral music)
(cool jazz music)
(swishing)
(swooshing)
- Just tell me, how bad is it?
- I'm sorry to say, in
spite of your mild symptoms,
(depressing violin playing)
you only have a few hours to live.
(cool jazz music)
- Just tell me, how bad is it?
- It's just a mild cold,
you'll be fine in a few days.
- Whew.
(upbeat rock music)
- Hey you guys, okay.
- Hey! (laughing)
- Yay!
(neighbor snoring loudly)
(dopey music)
(upbeat alternative music)
- Clean bill of health.
- Great!
It looks like your insurance
covered everything,
so all we need from you is a $10 co-pay.
(swooshing)
(upbeat alternative music)
- Clean bill of health.
(music stops abruptly)
- Congratulations.
That'll be $40,000.
(angry dramatic horns)
- Do you validate parking?
- Of course not.
(upbeat rock music)
(swishing)
(hinge squeaking)